there's an old saying that advises
performers to never work with children
or animals after all they both lack the
self control of adult humans and if they
don't feel like working they just won't
here are some films in which animals
wreaked havoc while the cameras were
rolling mr. Popper's Penguins Jim Carrey
loves to goof around on the set riffing
on lines making outrageous sounds and
teasing co-stars it's all part of the
Jim Carey package but if he messes
around a bit too long not all of mr.
Popper's Penguins are gonna put up with
it I'll introduce you some he was
charged
[Music]
okay sometimes when you hit command come
here no Outlander this historical TV
series is full of serious dramatic
moments a set on the battlefields of
18th century Scotland but behind the
scenes certain actors marched to the
beat of their own drum and to go by
their own schedule take for example the
horse who didn't feel like waiting until
the scene was finished to take care of
personal business quite enough
The Lone Ranger Disney's attempt to
reboot The Lone Ranger was also an
attempt to revive the old-school
big-screen Western as a result army
hammer and Johnny Depp spend large
portions of the movie on horseback all
that time together led to what looks
like an on-set romance or at least a
crush I love you travel but no Charles
fire
[Music]
okay don't come to your faker Margar
anchorman in this ridiculous classic
anchorman Will Ferrell's character Ron
Burgundy winds up a shell of a man
located in well and it's all because he
threw a burrito out the window and hits
a biker who responded by punting runs
beloved dog Baxter off a bridge but
behind the scenes it appears the actor
playing Baxter could sense the danger
ahead because I will give you a rap on
the Jack Johnson you hear me all right
now this is gonna happen
yep he doesn't like you and command to
the beginning of anchorman - it shows
Ronnie getting the old news team from
anchorman back together he finds Paul
Rudd's character ace reporter Brian
Fantana working as a highly esteemed
kitten photographer but some on the set
tension between the models may have led
to some well cat fights the interview
German Shepherds are one of the most
fearsome breeds of dog liable to maim a
murder and dismember at their train that
way or apparently that rage can be
redirected
unfortunately for Seth Rogen in the
interview the scenes he shot with an
extremely friendly German Shepherd also
required nudity The Hangover dogs are
essentially professional people liqueurs
while filming The Hangover Zach
Galifianakis established a very special
bond with the dog named Tucker although
it doesn't seem like it was always the
dog he was doing the licking
okay so much peanut butter in my beard
right now the proposal you'd think
acting opposite oscar-winning movie star
and America's Sweetheart Sandra Bullock
would get actors to behave
professionally and keep a laser focus on
their scene partner apparently not all
actors Late Night with Conan O'Brien
during a taping of an episode of his old
NBC show in 2007 Conan O'Brien ports out
to duck the valtor plan as to what to do
with their well the duck had his own
idea we don't even have an idea for my
the bit was so well received that
O'Brien brought the duck back naming him
Quackers the heating duct
thanks for watching take the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love tune
[Applause]